the man convicted of killing 20-year-old
mollie tibbetts is asking for a new
trial
christian bohena rivera was supposed to
be sentenced
to life in prison yesterday for the 2018
murder of the university of iowa student
instead a judge is now considering
possible new evidence
the defense supports rivera's testimony
of being kidnapped and framed
for her murder meg oliver joins us now
with more on this new twist in the case
may good morning to you gail good
morning this case was supposed to be
done today but now many are blindsided
by the defense's new claims
they say new information from two
separate witnesses
could have helped their client's case
instead pointing to an alleged sex
trafficking ring that may have been
involved in tibbetts
and other local disappearances molly
tibbetts
was abducted for the purposes of sex
trafficking
attorneys for christian beheena rivera
say two new witnesses
claim a man confessed to killing mollie
tibbetts after she was abducted and held
for sex
trafficking at a home that could be
connected to other disappearances
in the area we have information that
three
people have vanished out of thin air
in this small rural county
after his arrest rivera led
investigators to her body in a cornfield
and told them he murdered tibbetts but
at his trial in may rivera a mexican
national
testified he was kidnapped at gunpoint
by two men
and forced to drive them to a rural road
where he said they passed tibbetts
jogging
he claimed a man got out of his car with
a knife stabbed tibbetts to death and
put her body in the trunk
rivera said the men threatened to hurt
his family before leaving him to dispose
of her body
molly tibbetts was in the trunk of your
car isn't that right
yes and you did not tell them
what really happened isn't that right
correct the jury and prosecution
dismissed rivera's claims
we the jury find the defendant christian
bahina rivera guilty of the crime of
murder in the first degree
both witnesses came forward to
authorities during rivera's trial
claiming the same man bragged about
tibbetts kidnapping
in murder one witness claimed the man
said he and another person
decided to dump her body near a hispanic
male
in order to make it appear that the
hispanic male committed the crime
because of the publicity surrounding her
disappearance
but defense attorneys say they were only
told about one witness
after they rested their case the other
after the verdict
they say the witness information could
bolster their defense
but prosecutors say there are
differences between rivera's testimony
and the new accounts
and they disagree that her abduction
could be part of a trafficking ring
there's no evidence that we're aware of
that a sex trafficking house exists
in powersheet county mitch mortvette
oversaw the tibbetts case for the iowa
department of criminal investigation
why do you remain confident in the
investigation and conviction of rivera
the evidence that was discovered you
know her blood was in his trunk of his
vehicle
and again the statements that he gave
that all came out during trial that's
where our confidence lies
the defense noted blood tests from
rivera's trunk showed dna from people
other than tibbetts
they are also requesting information
from prosecutors on sex trafficking
investigations in the region
the judge that he expects to have a
decision regarding the potential
evidence by the week's end
we reached out to the tibbetts family
for their reaction but they have
declined to comment i can imagine this
is very
confusing and disturbing for them three
years ago this sunday molly
tibbetts disappeared so painful yeah meg
thank you